- I am feeling so defeated.
I'm doing so bad at this.
- Yeah you are!
Oh my God!
Oh, it's on your fingers.
- Hi I'm Dani.
- And I'm Ari.
- And we've been best
friends since we were nine.
- And now we live together.
- And we're trying to
make less food waste.
- I try my best to live zero waste
and not make plastic trash,
but I think I need to take a hard look
at the food waste that I create.
- I just love things that are convenient.
The world's burning,
and we gotta do better.
- Each week we're gonna be
emptying out our fridge,
and weighing all the food we wasted to
keep ourselves more accountable.
- This is such a privilege issue.
It really is.
Just like oh waste this food.
Alright.
Oh.
These lemon bars that are
definitely no good anymore.
We can recycle.
- It's a number six.
That probably actually won't get recycled.
- Really?
- Yeah.
This is my fault.
This is pozole.
- Oh.
This is some meat that's
probably not good anymore.
Where did these avocados?
- That's my fault.
- Got a weed chocolate bar?
It's still good.
- We're gonna weigh the food waste
from our fridge from this week.
- Oh.
- Four pounds, 13 ounces.
- We did good.
- I don't know.
It's okay.
We're gonna try to do better.
Four pounds hopefully to zero pounds.
- Yes, or like maybe one ounce,
because let's be real I'm a person.
- We're seeing if anything
needs to be eaten in here.
- Nope, I mean maybe some cilantro.
I already ate some of
the vegan mac and cheese.
- That's what I'm gonna have for dinner.
Oh.
- Is that not enough?
- No, oh.
- You told me I can have some.
- Yep.
I have all these grand plans of
all the meals I'm gonna make,
but then I work full time.
Then things slip through the cracks,
and then I end up wasting food.
I got these leftovers from a restaurant,
and look at me I'm like I'm waste free.
I put it in a jar,
but then I didn't eat it.
And so I wasted it.
- So I'm at my boyfriends house,
because I'm in and out
so much I've wasted this.
It's been about a week,
and it's looking sad.
- There was some sad looking carrots
and spinach in the fridge,
so I made them into a soup.
- This is not good.
Doesn't smell bad,
but it's not good.
This squash is mine and it went bad.
Oh, this is bad.
What is this?
- It's old lettuce.
- It looks like a turd.
- It's some old lettuce.
- This is Ari's.
She wasted an entire thing of milk.
- I was gonna make yogurt
and then it didn't happen.
I made a soup and it got old.
- Yeah.
Ew.
- I thought we were gonna do better.
- Yeah, this kinda stressed me out.
Ah.
Wow, that milk's really
adding some poundage.
Just sayin'.
Yep, alright.
So let's see.
- If you minus the weight of the bowl.
We wasted 5.4 pounds of wet food.
- Here's to not sucking next week.
- We can do it.
- Here is our compost,
which we keep in the freezer.
So this other food waste,
we actually can compost.
When food scraps go into a trashcan,
they get suffocated in a plastic bag.
Then they go to a landfill
where they off gas methane,
which is a greenhouse gas.
So composting food scraps and food waste
is a way to keep methane
out of our environment.
- It's hard like for memory,
and even just like getting
things in styrofoam.
And I know that that's not
the purpose of this challenge.
This challenge is to not waste food,
but then like get it in
styrofoam to like save it.
Then I'm just creating double waste,
and I just kinda feel like oh my God.
- I really wanted to go out
to lunch with my friend,
but instead I'm gonna eat these leftovers.
- Yeah, Ari's nasty as hell.
Look at this (bleep).
What the (bleep) is this?
Why?
- I made a fridge soup with all of the
odds and ends vegetables that
I have leftover in my fridge.
And it's pretty tasty.
- Alright, ready?
This is a sandwich.
Here's some tofu that went really bad.
- I wasted these mushrooms.
- You always waste mushrooms.
- I admit it's a problem.
I wasted this salmon.
- No, it's on your finger!
Wow that smells really bad.
- It's only a pound.
I think we have gotten better though.
- Yeah.
I just made some nut milk,
and then with the nut milk
pulp from the cheesecloth
I made some dope granola
bars and papita meal.
I'm gonna use this papita meal to
make a vegan deconstructed ratatouille.
- Instead of wasting this very old banana,
I'm freezing it and then I'm
gonna use it for some smoothies.
My goal tonight is to have a little
dinner of hodgepodge leftovers.
Ratatouille tacos.
Da ta da da.
- [Both] Da, da, da, da, da da.
- Da da.
So, let's look at my damage.
Remember this guy?
Got these ice creams,
because I was really stoned.
Technically I haven't really wasted much.
- I wasted a half of an avocado
and these yellow squash.
- That is nine ounces of waste.
Okay.
- Nine ounces of waste.
That's not bad.
Guys, this is really hard.
DJ Khaled was right they
don't want us to win,
but you know we're gonna win,
because we are taking
steps to being better.
It's not about being perfect.
It's about taking steps to be better.
- I totally agree.
It's such a privilege to be
able to have food to waste.
- This challenge has made me
expand the way that I cook.
How to make food stretch.
My mom would be really proud of me.
I guess like an Afro-Latina mom.
She'd be like, "Wow Mira,
this good, this good.
"You don't wasting shit."
- High five.